Hey gang, Dave Baker.
Today we're going to talk about
some of my favorite pole arms
featured on "Forged in Fire."
[music playing]
Historically, the pole
arm is a standoff weapon.
It keeps your
enemy the distance.
You fight off enemy cavalry
and infantry, keeping
them out of sword's range.
Now this beauty is
the German halberd.
German halberd was used
starting in the 14th century
consisting of an ax head, a
spear point, and a hooked back.
It can be used to
chop an opponent,
pull someone off a horse,
or push a ladder off a wall.
Whew.
It will kill.
Now the name of
this weapon, halberd,
comes from the German words
halm, meaning staff, and bart,
meaning axe.
Sounds brutal, Dave.
You can still see
these halberds being
used at ceremonial events.
This is the glaive guisarme.
Now a glaive is basically a
large sword blade on a pole.
This is a widely used weapon
from the 13th and 14th century
in Europe.
Now the glaive gave
the ability to thrust
as well as slash,
just like a pole.
It can also be used to
push an object away.
I'd say that's pretty good.
So glaives and weapons
like them were often
used by second line troops.
Standing behind the front
line or shield wall,
you could reach over and stab
into your opponent's line.
This weapon is sharp.
Thank you.
This weapon is
the qinglong ji.
Now the qinglong ji
is almost a marrying
of a spear and a halberd.
With this wavy blade for
thrusting and slashing,
the hook for either hooking or
chopping into an opponent, that
gave a warrior, a
certain amount of reach,
but it wasn't as long
as a lot of pole arms.
The qinglong ji was a
costly blade to make.
So it was often reserved
for palace guards or the
upper echelon of the military.
The qinglong ji was
a like, fast blade.
And on the battlefield, if you
were facing a line of these,
you weren't moving forward.
This weapon is the bardiche.
The bardiche is a Russian weapon
from the 16th, 17th century,
most famously used by a group
called the Streltsy, which
were an elite musketeer group.
Their heavy muskets were
laid across the axe's
blade to stabilize it.
Once the musket was
fired, it could be dropped
and the bardiche picked
up as troops charged.
Nice.
Right on, brother.
These are a light,
well-designed weapons.
Remember, on the
battlefield, you
need the carry this with one
hand and a 16-pound musket
in the other.
That will really slow you down.
Oh, ha, ha.
It's a light, fast deadly
weapon with a colorful history.
This wild looking weapon
is the jumonji yari.
The yari was used by Japanese
infantry in the 15th century
either to fight off
other infantry units
or mounted samurai.
Geezus.
The jumonji yari
or the trident yari
is different than the standard
yari in that the standard yari
just has a point.
The jumonji with these
arms actually made
it a better defensive weapon.
On the 15th century
Japanese battlefield,
this weapon was both
offense and defense.